sono innamorato folle di un futuro
parete del the wire e guai overture è
stato un bacio
ripeto non è ancora 3 the nulla sono
molto molto disperata perché purtroppo
lo vedo tutti i giorni ed è privo
ti prego di aiutarmi che devo fare e ti
prego non rispondermi farti sua
intanto la parola è stata usata a parigi
contro la parola breve infatti non
bisognerebbe però allora io grazie al
cielo ho un passato di catechismo
cresima che si lavoratore sia solamente
fino al nero si lo so ho una
considerazione da fare siamo prima di
tutto io una chiacchieri na con questo
ragazzo la farei imprecisamente
soprattutto nel momento in cui c'è stato
un bacio ma se tu credi di avere una
vocazione nei confronti della chiesa
insomma allora quel punto di vista e
quindi pensi anche che quella che tu hai
ricevuto è stata una chiamata
non pensi allo stesso tempo che sia
proprio dio invece di averti messo
questa ragazza davanti per farti remo
aspetta un secondo le 6 0 6 da meno
esatto se invece decidi di vivere una
vita laica con una ragazza potrebbe
essere se le chiede il signore sono
infinite
io questa la vedo anche un po come
un'autostrada sinceramente l'amore non è
una tentazione capitò del male in bocca
al lupo a temi aggiornato fammi sapere
governo come vanno le cose
oppure fatti suona ciao ragazzi
bentornati a una nuova puntata di vita
buttata il tema della puntata di oggi è
la posta del cuore
adesso fino ad oggi vita buttate sempre
stato un contenitore nel quale si
scherzava si rideva si facevano battute
ma fondamentalmente ho sempre pensato di
provare a trasformare vita buttata anche
in un posto nel quale fari chiacchiera
ve lo metto in grassetto quello di oggi
è un esperimento in realtà volevo fare
da un sacco di tempo ma ho aspettato
proprio questo giorno per poterlo
mettere in pratica perché ho pensato di
vedere in che modo vita buttata può
evolversi e in quante cose possono
essere racchiusi all'interno di questo
format
detto questo per una puntata così
speciale ho pensato di invitare
all'interno degli studios di casa mia
una persona che ha reso questo giorno
vorrei dire meno traumatico come san
valentino fa proprio schifo vennero
trovati esatto sto parlando di luigi
ciao il giorno di san valentino per me è
un giorno inutile quando ero single
io vedevo le coppie fidanzate fuori
pensavo dio che schifo adesso sono
fidanzato penso di anch'io sono tra loro
che schifo
ma perchè queste smancerie è proprio
contro risultano una ipo le faremo delle
smancerie però san valentino quindi
insomma predico bene e razzola male dal
allora siamo pronti in via spero che le
nostre considerazioni non siano infinite
poracci cioè se guardano il signore
degli anelli e fanno prima si leggono la
bibbia e fanno prima leggono un trattato
di psicologia sulle relazioni di coppia
e fanno prima risolviamo i problemi di
cuore
ciao ciao io ho bisogno di un consiglio
perché sono fidanzata da nove anni in
casa quindi anche con la famiglia
però mi sono accorta di non amare tu non
eri lanciato ormai da tre anni tre reti
se rilasciarlo ma come
mi date qualche consiglio ne sarei molto
sanremo sta roba
io non sono bravo io sì questa è tosta
questo nel trattare con i guanti di
velluto a tivoli un attimo aprire gli
occhi su quello che accadrà allora tu
dovessi continuare a comportarsi in
questo modo ipotesi a passeranno altri 5
6 7 8 anni 9 10 farete dei figli e tu
sarai per altri 7 8 9 10 anni infelice
che sta insieme a una persona che alla
poi sicuramente vorrà un bene dell'anima
ma che allo stesso tempo non riesci ad
amare perché non puoi scegliere la
persona che ti attrae qui non c'entra un
discorso di cattiveria però è molto
importante in questi casi il modo e le
modalità quello che ti dico io è
l'ipotesi b potrebbe essere ancora
peggiore che vivere una vita infelice
ossia passa un anno passano due anni e
mentre fa la spesa ti innamori
follemente di qualcuno che ti fa fare
così grande per cui tu a un certo punto
blu galizzi il tuo ragazzo lo manga
all'improvviso e tifare una vita con
questo qui perché perché tu hai tutti
questi anni di frustrazione alle spalle
per cui automaticamente comincia a
diventare insopportabile scontrosa
perché perché speri che la scelta la
faccia l'altro di mollarti no quando
succedono cose importanti bisogna anche
comportarsi in maniera importante e
secondo me la persona che il tuo
compagno vorrebbe al proprio fianco e
vorrebbe che gli facesse questo discorso
se solamente te quindi il mio consiglio
è prendi dalla leggera non serve per
forza dire senti è finita ma anche
incominciare a aprire questo discorso e
spiegare magari anche che sei disposta a
metterti in gioco perché la cosa più
brutta è farsi un'idea di una persona e
poi di colpo avere una persona che ti
sveglia con l'acqua fredda e renderti
conto che in realtà tu per gli ultimi
anni si è stato solamente a immaginare
un mondo che non esiste io sono sicuro
che anche se non ami più questa persona
tu nei suoi confronti nutra una forma di
amore magari diverso da quello iniziale
ecco appendi t a quello di non rovinare
quella roba di cavi di trasformare
una roba lì in un ponte ti ho detto che
sono bravo d'accordo ma cosa miglioravo
bravo bravo che non c'entro una
cattiveria la cattiveria subentra il
momento in cui ti comporti male allora
ciao guglielmo cosa regalare alla mia
ragazza per san valentino ti dico
soltanto che l'anno scorso siamo
riusciti a dichiararci la stessa
identica cosa per chi non lavora luce di
un porcospino visto che ti segue tanto
lei è potenzialmente tu potresti leggere
e rispondere a questo messaggio vocale
per chi non essere tu il regalo di san
valentino
allora cara sai perché con fiocchetto
non voglio un fiocchetto cara sara
l'anno scorso ricevuto un peluche
pensavi che il tuo ragazzo non poter
scavare più in basso e invece ci è
riuscito ma sia ce l'ha fatta perché il
tuo regalo di san valentino nemmeno lo
riceverà io perché è un video un piccolo
saluto da parte mia
buon san valentino auguri ciao ragazzi
non posso dire che questa cosa però dei
regali e terribile mattia sentiva sola
cosa ma mi fai un video invece per lui e
così se tu il regalo di san valentino
perché io non ho idea
volevo dirti che io sono stata lasciata
due mesi fa prima di natale perché dopo
due anni di relazioni e lui ha deciso
che nel suo futuro si vede da solo e che
non volevo più stare con non perché
erano andasse bene ma era proprio detto
non prenderla sul personale ormai il
giro
ciao bella bella
terminare una relazione dopo un mese due
anni 5 10
non è un crimine non state facendo
qualcosa di sbagliato però dipende tutto
da come lo fate lo fate e dei motivi che
date prendere in giro una persona con la
quale essere stati è una cosa veramente
brutta e soprattutto aver il tatto di un
rinoceronte
quindi per favore potete prendere
esempio dalla storia di questa ragazza
per capire qual è ha meno una delle
tante cose che non dovete fare
dimostrate proprio di non avere un
minimo di b
guarda ti posso dire una cosa veramente
col cuore una persona che dopo due anni
dice una cosa così ma veramente ma
buttava via perché se dopo due anni
questo è il rispetto che riesce a darti
queste sono le motivazioni che riesce a
darti non è veramente fatta per stare
insieme alle persone non è manco fatta
per stare insieme con se stesso lo credo
che possiate perde tra le gambe della
gente il fatto che tu ci stia male è
normale e mostra che sei una persona
normale che ha un collegamento con la
propria emotività e con i propri
sentimenti normale cosa lui no che
schifo camuffare la voce quante voci
camuffate quando persone che non
vogliono far sapere quando si parla
d'amore per ragazze più che siete così
subdoli dai costi clinica buttate libro
racconta la tragica situazione in cui io
sono una ragazza molto molto molto molto
molto alta questo senso ma la mia di
sosta nel trovare letteralmente qualcuno
desse la mia altezza
quindi io lavo c'erano consiglio anche
perché effettivamente ci potrebbe essere
qualcuno in questo momento mi interessa
cioè nell'ironico cosa si fa in questi
casi non ti lasci scoraggiare da ste
robe
nel senso se uno ti piace magari siete
sulla stessa linea d'onda ragazzi che
vuole dire no facciamo una cosa invece
più utile ai ragazzi all'ascolto se
siete i suoi due metri che siete alti mi
scrivete oppure segnati tipo a pallavolo
basket in modo che la squadra maschile
solitamente rasente 7 metri e mezzo
secondo me hagrid potrebbe essere
un'altra mossa cioè basta aspettare che
le api vengano al miele ma buttiamo
rinviene in quell'alveare con l'accordo
un bravo ottimo dritto kim e ragazzo a
san valentino ha deciso di andati a
vedere la partita di padrone allo stadio
così ho dovuto annullare il ristorante è
già prenotato lomazzo lo lascio da un
consiglio di una cosa io sono dell'idea
che la metà della mela non lo troverai
mai anche perché due metà di una mela
non possono attaccarsi a meno che non ci
metti e il bostik tu devi cercare
l'altra metà del puzzle
a incastro devi andare capito quindi
deve essere ovviamente una persona
diversa da te perché altrimenti non si
crea l'incastro una persona però i cui
difetti tu riesci a sopportare poteva
andare a vedere un'altra il giorno di
san valentino con le cose importanti
sono altre però magari una ragazza sai
ci sia però mi sembrava sorridente non
mai fatti ci ride sopra da sola ma
verona dove c'è anche passata sopra di
dirlo la prova quanto le forze degli
slot mi si scusi stile molto semplice
perché tutti partiamo dal presupposto
che 17 anni si è molto giovane esatto ed
è quindi normale che tutto quello che ti
stia capitando sia ancora una novità ed
è la cosa meravigliosa dell'avere lato
rita florit allo stesso tempo primo
questo ragazzo siamo sicuri che sia gay
secondo questo ragazzo siamo sicuri che
sia affidabile perché se non sei pronto
a uscire così allo scoperto il dello
sconsiglio sinceramente per questa cotta
e per questa curiosità di buttarti in
una nave che non può reggere le onde più
avuto un sacco di cotte al liceo e per
le tue stesse paure
io non mi sono mai diciamo esposto non
parlato perché comunque era una cosa
nuova e ancora non sapevo esattamente
come gestirla il mio invito di darti
tempo da il mio invito è quello di darti
del tempo senza contare che esiste un
sacco di modi un pochino più sicuri per
incontrare persone senza doverti per
forza così esporre o anche per
confrontarsi con altre persone
se vuoi correre allacciati prima le
scarpe allacciate allora puoi fare
quello che ti pare ma non pensare al
traguardo sia stata di scalzi mia
ragazza che cosa sta succedendo
secondo me è stata la banca re con
qualsiasi cosa tu dovessi scegliere in
bocca le commodity tutto serio perché
sei giovane ci sarà un cuore di cosa
dovrei farneti spezzeranno il cuore
perdere la testa troverai l'amore le
cose andranno bene le cose andranno male
bellissimo in realtà ho fatto ora un
discorso da vecchio sei dentro ciò che
immagino sia una donna
diciamo anche io sì sì bella scusa il
sottofondo di cartello del consiglio
vorrei chiederti un piccolo favore in
quanto il regalo che vorrei fare
siamo una piccola sorpresa che vorrei
fare è quello appunto di un
un messaggio di auguri trovo sia una
cosa originale che non si può comprare
da nessuna parte
io volevo che appunto si potesse essere
tu a fare gli auguri alla mia ragazza
che si chiama francesca tantissimo
quindi accanto una tua risposta e magari
di vederlo nel suo video grazie mille a
io mi chiamo al e così se nel video lo
vuoi viene si capisce allora ci vuole un
certo che vorrei
non voglio un biglietto cara francesca
lo in questi casi non si canto tanti
auguri a te non vale a meno cara
francesca che dire alex il tuo fidanzato
ti voleva mandare un messaggio tramite
questo video per dirti che ti ama tanto
che se il suo amore che cosa carina
molto e per dirti che ci teneva a
regalarti qualcosa che non si può
comprare e chi vuol dire che non può
manco restituirlo dove l'imbarazzo
godetevi la serata
datevi tanti bacetti carini e
promettetemi tante cose belle e
mantenere queste cose belle e
soprattutto il tuo ragazzo è molto molto
simpatico molto fa troppo ridere quindi
territorio stretto vorrei gli uomini
così sono rari raris soggettivi squadre
son finiti a lei anche siamo veramente
un po di alex era una battuta dal caso
mi dispiace francesca allora ragazzi io
direi un secondo visto che questo video
sta andando molto molto per le lunghe di
prenderci una pausa chiuderla qui e
dividere questo video in due parti
quindi se volete maggiori informazioni
su quando uscirà la seconda parte di
questo video guardate qua sotto le di
tempo box in modo da poter rimanere
aggiornati buon san valentino che
passano amore
se no veramente cioè non finiamo più
ragazzino non finiamo più grazie al no
ai messaggini grazie ciao